if we were to buy the stock for fifty
dollars so this is a situation where
we're buying the stock we're clearly
putting fifty dollars up front and if
the stock moved up to eighty dollars and
we were able to perfectly call the top
and sell it for that eighty dollars we
would make a thirty dollar profit off of
a fifty dollar initial investment so
that's a sixty percent gain that's a
sixty percent gain on our upfront
capital now on the other side if the
stock were to go down to twenty dollars
we would lose thirty dollars
of our fifty dollar upfront investment
so it would be a sixty percent loss so
in the buying the stock
based on the scenario that i painted we
could gain sixty percent or we could
lose sixty percent and in terms of the
potential upside you can gain an
unlimited amount because the stock can
just really go to any possible value and
in terms of loss when you buy a stock
the most you can lose is a hundred
percent now let's think about the
scenario with the call option
call
with the call option to buy the call
option it only cost us five dollars so
we only had to put five dollars up front
and in the scenario where where the
stock went up to eighty dollars we
figured out that we were able to profit
fifteen dollars net of the price of the
option so this was our pure profit so be
on a base of a five dollar investment we
were able to get fifteen dollars of
profit so we were able to get a 300
percent gain
we were able to get a 300 gain on the
other side though if the stock went down
we had no reason to actually exercise
our option so we essentially just lost
all of the money of the option so we
lost 100
we lost 100 and what i want to show here
is that what an option did is it gave us
leverage
it gave us leverage and the term comes
from physics because a lever will give
you kind of mechanical leverage it can
allow you to exert more force than you
otherwise could by using that simple
tool and a call option is giving you
financial leverage
you're essentially making the same bet
here but you're multiplying your
potential gain or your potential loss if
the stock you in based on the scenario
we painted in the good scenario you made
sixty percent but in the call option in
the good scenario you made three hundred
percent we multiplied multiplied our
gain but on the downside with the stock
we lost sixty percent but with the call
option we lost 100
so once again we multiplied our loss and
right here it looks like the numbers are
still favorable because our our loss
multiplication wasn't as much as our
gain multiplication but this is really
based on some of the numbers i chose but
the important thing to realize
is if you're dealing with an option to
essentially make the same bet that the
bet that the company will go up you're
just putting leverage on your bet you're
multiplying your potential gains or
losses